[música]
เฮ
>> [música]
[música]
>> Olá, pessoal. Tudo bem com vocês? Que
maravilha encontrá-los aqui hoje.
Estamos iniciando agora mais um encontro
de direito civil aqui ao vivo para você
no canal do grão AB. Quero mandar um
beijo para todo mundo que tá aí
acompanhando a gente nesse exato
momento. Robson, que diz que gosta do
empresarial, mas não perde uma aula de
direito civil. Amanda estudar até
passar. Já estou por aqui. Bom dia a
todos. Maria Cristina, Dra. Neid, um
beijo. Gabriel, Bianca, Júnior, Juliana,
um beijo pro Mauro, Dani, Moara,
Shirley, João, Alícia. Um beijo Alice
que não me larga, tá sempre comigo. Se
tem uma coisa que eu tenho certeza na
vida é que eu não dou aula sozinha.
Alícia tá sempre comigo. Elana, um
beijo. Luía
ou é Luía Arnaldo. Luía Arnaldo, um
beijo, Ana Carol. Tá. Um beijo para
vocês. Edemar.
Um beijo. Luí, gente, ó o povo. Ele
Helena Cordeiro, eu sou do IMP. Ai, que
coisa linda, Carolina. Um beijo. A
Jacira do IMP, que eu quando eu dou aula
presencial eu coloco o nome nos meus
alunos. Jácira tá aí na área. Beijo. Bom
dia. Bom dia. Bom dia. Bom dia. Amo
muito vocês. Fico muito feliz com vocês
aqui. Hoje vamos conversar sobre direito
civil, tá? Deixa eu aumentar um
pouquinho meu áudio aqui, porque o
pessoal tá falando que tá baixo.
E vamos lá, vê se melhorou aí um
pouquinho. Bom, a gente tá, a gente vai
falar sobre direito das famílias.
Vamos fazer um esquema geralzão. O povo
de Sinope, um beijo, viu? A galera de
Sinope que tá aí, Mariana,
Mônica.
Ai, gente, eu fico tão feliz com a
presença de vocês. É. Nós queóis. Pois
bem, aumentou o áudio, aumentou um
pouquinho mais. É porque daqui a pouco
eu começo a gritar e o áudio começa a
estourar e é uma confusão
tenebrosa. Mas a gente vai ajustando, a
gente vai trocando o pneu com carro em
andamento e é sobre. É porque eu quando
eu tô começando, eu começo a falar
baixo. Daqui a pouco eu tô gritando,
berrando e olha o caminhão da provação
passando na sua rua.
Agora ela falou: "Abaixa um pouquinho
que agora estourou".
Baixei.
Muito bem. Então vamos lá. Direito das
famílias. A gente já conversou sobre
sucessões, agora a gente vai falar sobre
amor ou não, né? Ou você que achou que
era o presente de Deus, na verdade era
só uma lembrancinha.
Ou então não era presente do Papai do
Céu, era presente do Papai da Terra.
Vamos lá. Abaixei um pouquinho. Dá uma
olhada aí se o áudio tá melhor.
Margarida de Barbalha no Ceará. Pois
muito que bem, viu?
Um beijo, beijo, beijo. Vamos lá. Deixa
eu só confirmar com a minha patroa aqui
se tá tudo certo.
Pois muito que bem. Vamos embora, né,
gente? O alecrm dourado. O alecrm
dourado era sem cor, não era dourado,
era queimado. O povo de Olinda. Ô meu
Deus, como eu amo Olinda, gente. Queria
morar lá. Seguinte, é, queria morar no
Recife, ir para Olinda todo dia. Minha
patroa disse que agora tá bom o som. O
povo de Diamantina,
tá bom? Pode, pode me avisar que eu tô
de olho aqui no chat.
Beijo, viu? Pois muito que bem. Vamos
falar de amor, vamos falar de direito
das famílias hoje, fazendo o nosso
esquema do coração. E eu já quero
começar falando com você um pouquinho
sobre a questão
de casamento, de união estável, de
divórcio e biibi e bobó. Pois muito que
bem, vamos lá, iniciando os nossos
esquemas do coração, quero começar
falando aqui com você o seguinte.
Dentro dessa estrutura de família, a
gente tem a chamada pluralidade
familiar. Vem comigo aqui que eu vou
explicar isso para você. A gente tem a
chamada pluralidade familiar.
Consideramos
justa
toda [canto]
forma de amor.
Família hoje é pautada no afeto, no
amor. A gente trabalha o conceito da
família eonista,
que é a família pautada no afeto. Então,
tanto a Constituição Federal quanto o
Código Civil vem no sentido de ter eh
a observância de que família é pautada
no amor, no afeto. Então, a gente não
pode considerar como família somente o
casamento. A gente tem a união estável,
a gente tem a família eh formada pelos
pais e seus filhos, né? Ou só pelo pai e
seus filhos, só pela mãe e seus filhos.
A gente tem a família isoparental de uma
pessoa só. A gente tem a família dos
avós com os netos, a família dos irmãos,
a família multispéccie, que é o meu
caso, cinco cachorros, sete gatos.
Então, eh, a gente tem variados
conceitos de família. família é onde a
gente se sente feliz, onde a gente
encontra apoio, onde a gente encontra
afeto, onde a gente encontra, né, o
nosso núcleo de proteção, ainda que nós
estejamos fazendo coisas que aos olhos
dos nossos familiares não estão
corretas, eles apoiam a gente, né? a
família se fecha em torno da pessoa.
Sorte daquele que tem uma família assim,
eu, graças a Deus, tenho. Então, a gente
trabalha o conceito de família de
maneira variada, mas é óbvio que
legalmente falando e de uma maneira até
dura e formal, ingessada aqui, previsto
na lei, a gente tem que trabalhar com
aspectos
eh objetivos. Então a gente vai falar
pra nossa prova do casamento e da união
estável, que é o que realmente cai em
prova e a gente quer ser aprovado. Aí
depois que você for aprovado ou não, ou
agora você vem fazer uma pós-graduação
comigo aqui no GRAM, porque eu coordeno
três cursos de pós: de advocacia
privada, de direito imobiliário e
condominial e de direito do consumidor.
São três cursos assim, ó, lindos, lindos
para você. Mas vamos lá. Olha só, eu vou
colocar aqui que a gente tem a questão
da união estável.
Vamos montar nossos esquemas do coração.
E nós temos a questão
do casamento.
A diferença entre um e outro
é que
na união estável nós vamos encontrar
simplesmente um fato da vida, tá? A
união estável é um fato
da vida. É um fato da vida que acontece
pela
convivência
pública
contínua
e
duradoura
com objetivo.
de
constituir
família. Então, quando a gente fala de
união estável, nós estamos falando de
uma situação que acontece na vida.
acontece na vida pela convivência
pública
contínua,
duradoura,
com objetivo de constituição de quê?
De família, tá? Com objetivo de
constituição de família. Esse é essa é a
união estável. Quando a gente fala de
união estável, você precisa
permanecer atento e lembrar, aliás, vou
botar assim, ó, permanecer atento
e lembrar que
para caracterizar a união estável,
Não,
não precisa,
não precisa
morar junto. Ah, professor, eu posso
morar na minha casa e a outra pessoa na
casa dele? Pode. Não precisa morar
junto,
não precisa ter filhos.
Não precisa
escritura pública.
Se você quiser fazer a escritura
pública, você faz para fingir
comprovação, mas para que a união
estável exista, eu não preciso de
escritura pública, tá? E não precisa
tempo mínimo.
Não precisa tempo mínimo.
Sâia colocou ali, união estável é prazo
mínimo de 2 anos para ser configurada.
Não, não tem prazo. Então, muito
cuidado. Para caracterizar a união
estável, eu não preciso,
não preciso
nem morar junto, nem ter filho, nem ter
tempo mínimo, tá? Não preciso fazer
obrigatoriamente
escritura pública. Também não preciso
observar isso.
Justamente por quê? Porque ela é um fato
da vida que surge da convivência pública
contínua e duradoura, com intuito de
constituição de família. Como eu tenho
toque,
eu vou arrumar isso aqui,
tá? Não precisa. Então, beleza, vamos
aos fatos importantes pra nossa prova.
Vamos lá tomar um cafezinho. C de quê?
Sempre foi assim, não? Antigamente tinha
prazo, tá, pela legislação. Porque o que
que acontece? A união estável, ela tem
previsão no artigo 1723 do Código Civil.
O nosso Código Civil é de 2002, passou a
ter vigência em 2003. Então, o que
regulava a união estável antes era uma
lei de 94 e uma lei de 96.
E aí, nesse caso, a gente aplicava essas
legislações e aí tinha prazo. Com o
Código Civil não há falar mais em prazo,
tá? Então eu posso ter uma união estável
caracterizada por um relacionamento de 2
meses, posso 3 meses, posso. Eu posso
ter uma um relacionamento de 15 anos que
não configura a união estável. Posso
também. O tempo não significa nada. O
que eu preciso é de uma união eh pública
contínua, duradoura, com intuito de
constituição de família. Vamos às
questões. O povo tenta fazer contrato de
namoro
para evitar a incidência da união
estável. O povo vai lá no cartório, faz
o tal do contrato de namoro para evitar
a incidência da união estável. Só que
tem um detalhe, gente, contrato de
namoro pode até ser válido, mas ele não
produz o efeito de evitar a união
estável, porque a união estável é um
fato da vida e você não consegue evitar.
e também o tal do namoro qualificado. O
STJ já decidiu sobre essa questão do
namoro qualificado.
Eh, o caso que aconteceu especificamente
foi um casal que foi estudar fora do
Brasil e acabaram morando juntos para
facilitar a vida, né, lá fora do Brasil.
Eles foram estudar e o menino, o rapaz
no na constância desse relacionamento
que eles tiveram, acabou comprando um
imóvel no Brasil. voltaram e a menina
pediu o reconhecimento da união estável
para partilhar aquele imóvel que foi
adquirido por ele. E ele falou: "Não,
mas a gente não tinha uma união estável,
a gente tinha um namoro". E o STJ falou:
"Olha, você pode até morar junto por uma
conveniência, você pode até misturar um
pouquinho os orçamentos para ajudar,
para, enfim, né? Mas o fato é que
simplesmente morar junto, simplesmente
ter uma ajuda mais intensa, mútua, não
caracteriza união estado, porque eu
preciso ter essa esse intuito de eh eu
preciso ter esse intuito de constituição
de família, né? É quando a gente fala do
objetivo de constituição de família, não
é um objetivo futuro, não é a intenção
de casar, é o objetivo de hoje. Hoje nós
somos uma família e fica aí essa
análise. E é assim que você diferencia o
namoro da união estável. Na união
estável você tem efetivamente uma
família. No namoro você não tem, né? O
namoro não é uma relação familiar.
O casamento, por sua vez, ele depende,
ele depende
da celebração.
Ele tem uma formalidade que começa no
cartório, eu vou desenhar para você já
já, tá? Ele tem uma celebração.
E como que eu provo provo o casamento?
Eu provo o casamento por meio de uma
certidão. A pessoa casada, ela tem uma
certidão de casamento, tá? Ela tem uma
certidão de casamento.
E aí eu quero que você observe uma coisa
muito importante que não é mais novidade
para ninguém. Não é novidade para
ninguém. Casamento
ou união estável. homoafetivo
é possível? Claro que é. Afinal de
contas, consideramos justa toda forma de
amor, tá? Então, não tem mais discussão.
Casamento entre homem e homem, mulher,
mulher. União estava entre homem e
homem, mulher, mulher, homem, mulher. Tá
tudo liberado. O que não tá liberado
ainda é o tal do poliamor. Eu não posso
ter um casamento e uma união estável ao
mesmo tempo. Não tenho como. Com toda a
certeza do mundo, a união estável será
considerada aí uma relação adulterina.
Então, se a pessoa já tem uma união
estável, ela não consegue contrair
outra. Se a pessoa tem uma uma um
casamento, ela não consegue ter uma
união estável, tá? Apesar de estarmos
caminhando paraa possibilidade de
reconhecer isso como uma relação
familiar, porque nós temos várias
situações, tá? A gente não pode pensar
assim: "Ah, é amante e tem que se
ferrar". Não, a gente, nós somos
operadores do direito e nós temos que
pensar, né, de maneira eh a contemplar a
opção de vida das pessoas.
É isso.
Mas é possível o casamento mal afetivo.
Um outro ponto também é que tanto no
casamento quanto no
na união estável, nós vamos ter,
tanto no casamento quanto na união
estável, nós vamos ter as regras sobre
regime de bens,
tá? Regime de bens.
E essa regra de regime de bens vai ser
aplicada em qualquer circunstância.
Qualquer circunstância,
seguindo
algumas regras.
Quais regras? Eu tenho regime de bens no
casamento e na união estável, observando
que o regime escolhido será
o mesmo para o casal.
o mesmo regime para o casal. É possível
você alterar o regime desde que você
faça de forma judicial,
tá? E a fixação,
a fixação
ela pode acontecer
pelo silêncio
dos envolvidos
ou por uma escolha.
Expressa.
Pelo silêncio dos envolvidos, nós vamos
ter o regime. Deixa eu arrumar isso
aqui.
Olha a professora com o toque.
No silêncio, nós vamos ter o regime da
comunhão parcial de bens, que é o
chamado regime supletório, tá?
E na escolha nós podemos ter comunhão
universal de bens,
participação final nos acquestos e
separação de bens.
OK? Então, a fixação ela pode acontecer
de maneira silenciosa.
A parte vai lá e define pelo silêncio. E
aí a gente vai ter o regime regra, que é
eh
que é
como é que fala?
Ninguém fala nada, né? O silêncio mesmo
vem a escolha tas ou por uma escolha
efetiva.
E aí eu faço por escrito comunhão
universal, participação final nosestos e
separação de bens. Eu quero que você dê
um print nessa tela aí.
Pois muito que bem. Seguindo o bonde, eu
quero que você observe o seguinte. Vamos
lá.
Casamento não seria somente entre homem
e mulher nas relações homoafetivas, não
seria o termo correto união estável?
Não, não, não, não, não, não. Tanto o
STJ quanto o STF já decidiram que tanto
o casamento quanto a união estável podem
ser homoafetivos,
tá? Vamos lá. Eu quero que você memorize
uma regra do coração. Quem não pode
casar não pode constituir união estável.
Vamos repetir juntos. Quem não pode
Quem não pode casar não pode constituir
uma união estável. De novo, quem não
pode casar não pode constituir uma união
estável. Professora, qual que é o artigo
do coração? O artigo 1521. Então, dá o
print.
Depois eu volto para você dar o print em
tudo se quiser. Mas a regra do coração é
quem
não
pode
casar
não
pode
constituir
união estável. Se ligou no esquema? Quem
não pode casar não pode constituir uma
união estável. Nada feito. Então aqui a
gente tem a nossa regra do coração. Quem
não pode casar não pode constituir união
estado. Professora, e quem é que não
pode casar?
Não pode casar quem consta
no artigo
1000 500
e 21,
que é o artigo que trabalha as regras do
impedimento para o casamento, tá? Então,
quem não pode casar
não pode
viver uma união estável, tá? Impedimento
pro casamento. Professora, quais são
essas regras? Eu quero a sua máxima
atenção agora. Quem são essas, quais são
essas situações? Vamos lá,
professora. Esse material você vai
disponibilizar,
vou só para quem entrar lá no meu
Instagram e clicar num link que eu vou
postar depois da aula e fazer a
inscrição seguinte. É, tá? Então, vamos
lá. Não podem casar. Quem é que
realmente
não pode se casar? Como eu tenho toque,
eu vou, né, gente, que eu sou dessas.
Quem é que realmente não pode casar?
Olha lá o que que nós temos aqui. Vamos
grifar. Vamos grifar porque a gente não
é besta. Vamos lá. Não podem casar os
ascendentes com os descendentes, pai com
filho, tá? Seja parentesco natural ou
civil. Parentesco natural, ascendente
comum, né? Parentesco consanguíneo.
Parentesco civil. O parentesco civil é
aquele que decorre da adoção e da
sócioafetividade.
Acabou.
Os afins em linha reta. Quem são os
afins em linha reta?
Sogro,
sogra,
ente,
enteada. Tá. Sogro, sogra, enteado.
Entiada. Ah, Roberta, mas eu já
divorciei, eu continuo sem poder casar
com meu sogro e com a minha sogra? Sim.
Por quê? Porque o legislador entende que
essas pessoas em um determinado momento
da vida, fizeram papel de pai e mãe.
Então, assim, fica estranho você casar
com essas pessoas, né?
O adotante,
o adotante
com quem foi cônjuge do adotado e do
adotado com quem foi do adotante, porque
vira sogro, sogra, né? Eh, eh,
genro, genra ou genro, genra, genro,
nora.
Os irmãos unilaterais ou bilaterais.
Óbvio que eu não posso casar com meu
irmão, tá?
e demais colaterais
até o terceiro grau,
demais colaterais
até o terceiro grau. Eu não posso eu não
posso me casar
com
o meu
eh
o meu tio e minha tia, tá? Eu não posso
me casar com meu tio e minha tia.
Roberta,
tio com sobrinho, então não pode não.
Mas cuidado, vou grifar isso aqui.
Terceiro grau, inclusive o tio com
sobrinho não pode.
Aí o que que a gente vai ter?
Que que a gente vai ter?
O decreto lei 3200.
Que que diz esse decreto lei 3200?
O decreto lei 3200 estabelece o
seguinte.
Ele estabelece que se os pais
eh
os pais
Pera aí
que eu me perdi.
Olha só.
Eh,
o que que vai acontecer?
Tio com sobrinho. Nossa, me deu um trem
aqui. Deixa eu tomar um café aqui, né,
gente? Deixa eu tomar um café aqui que
me deu um trem aqui. Primo, pode. Tá,
vamos lá. Tio com sobrinho pode, desde
que eles façam o exame
pelo decreto 3200 lá da década de 40,
atestando a sanidade mental deles e que
a próle não será defeituosa, tá?
a prol não será defeituosa.
Se tivesse exame, tio com sobrinho pode
casar de boa, de boa. Tá
aí também não pode casar, vou grifar
aqui de verde, o adotado com filho do
adotante, óbvio, e as pessoas casadas.
Não pode casar as pessoas casadas.
Roberta, se eu sou casado, eu não posso
casar? Não, não pode não. Não pode.
Claro que não, porque você tem uma
certidão de casamento
ativa, então você não pode casar. O
cônjuge sobrevivente com o condenado por
homicídio ou tentativa de homicídio
contra o seu consorte. Tá? Eu quero que
você entenda que quem não pode casar não
pode constituir uma união estável. Foi
isso que nós falamos. Aliás, o parágrafo
primeiro do 1723 diz isso, porque veja,
a união estável está prevista
no artigo
1723.
O parágrafo primeiro desse artigo diz o
seguinte,
olha só, o parágrafo primeiro desse
artigo diz que a união estável,
olha aqui, olha aqui, olha aqui, olha
aqui. Ah, ficou muito grande.
Olha lá, a união estável não se
constituirá.
Isso aqui já caiu em prova.
Se ocorrerem os impedimentos do 1521,
isso quer dizer que quem não pode casar
não pode viver uma união estável. Não
foi isso que a gente conversou? Foi.
Só que tem um detalhe.
Pessoa casada.
Pessoa casada
não pode casar.
Mas imagina
a seguinte situação.
Imagina a seguinte situação. A pessoa
está casada,
mas está separada de fato. Isso aqui já
caiu na prova. A pessoa casada separada
de fato. O que que é a separação de
fato? já não tá mais convivendo com o
outro, seguiu a vida, às vezes já até
saiu de casa, está separado de fato. E
já começou um outro relacionamento,
muito embora não tenha se divorciado, e
porque não se divorciou, não tem como
casar, porque tem uma certidão de
casamento ativa, como ele está separado
de fato, ele continua sem ter
possibilidade de casar, mas ele já pode
ter uma união estável. Então, se cair na
sua prova, sim. Por exemplo,
João,
João
é casado
com a Maria
desde 2010.
Desde 2010.
Em 2018, o João separou de fato da Maria
e ainda não formalizaram o divórcio.
Em 2020, mesmo sem ter formalizado o
divórcio,
o João se apaixona e começa a viver uma
união estável com a Antônia.
Com a Antônia.
A pergunta é esse relacionamento dele
aqui,
esse relacionamento dele aqui,
mesmo sem ter divorciado da Maria,
estando apenas separado de fato, isso
aqui pode caracterizar uma união
estável. Que que você me diz? Isso aqui
pode caracterizar uma união estável?
Sim, porque o parágrafo primeiro do 1723
diz o seguinte: "A união estável não vai
acontecer nas hipóteses em que eu não
posso me casar, mas não se aplica o
inciso 4 no caso de a pessoa casada
se achar separada de fato ou separada
judicialmente. A separação não é o
divórcio, é só uma separação. Então,
cuidado. Isso aqui caracteriza uma união
estável. Eu quero que você dê um print
categoria nessa tela, porque isso aqui
cai em prova, tá? Isso aqui
categoricamente cai em prova. Não tem
churumela.
Professora e o Hul que casou com a
sobrinha. A sobrinha não era sobrinha
dele, era sobrinha da esposa dele à
época. Então, não era parente dele. Você
não tem parentesco por afinidade com os
sobrinhos do seu cônjuge. Então, ele
podia ter eh casado ali de boa, de boa,
tá?
Ah,
ok. Belezura. Segue o bonde.
Não haverá, em hipótese nenhuma,
casamento de quem não tenha alcançado a
idade núbio. Qual que é a idade núbil?
Aos 16 anos. Vamos fazer um desenho
agora. Vamos lá.
Vamos lá. Dá o print aí.
Olha só.
Com quantos anos eu posso casar?
Com quantos anos
eu posso
me casar?
A idade Núbi para o casamento
é aos 16 anos. Então eu posso me casar
com 16 anos. Lidiane do IMP, um beijo,
viu? Um beijão. Obrigada por tá aqui. Eu
posso me casar com 16 anos, mas para eu
conseguir essa proeza
de me casar aos 16 anos, eu preciso ter
o quê? Eu preciso ter
o consentimento
dos pais.
Aí vem a questão.
Os meus pais podem me autorizar
ou eles podem não autorizar? Se os pais
derem o consentimento
e eu caso, acontece um fenômeno
chamado,
quem é que lembra?
emancipação.
Então, se eu caso com 16 anos, mediante
o consentimento dos meus pais, eu estou
emancipada, tá? Professora, casei com
16,
emancipei.
Divórcio
aos 17, permanece emancipado,
continua emancipado.
Segue emancipado. OK. Divórcio aos 17,
ele segue emancipado. Então, casou com
16. Isso aqui também já caiu na prova do
OAB. Casou com 16, divorcia aos 17 anos,
ele segue emancipado.
Se os pais não derem o consentimento,
olha que interessante, se os pais não
derem o consentimento, que que acontece
aqui?
O filho
pode ajuizar uma ação
ação
supletória
de
consentimento
contra os pais. Então, será uma ação
do filho
contra
os pais. Os pais são os réus. Que que é
que você aprende no processo civil? Que
quando
os pais são demandados pelos filhos, né?
O filho menor aqui, ele pode ser parte,
mas ele não tem capacidade de estar em
juízo. Então, o que que é que pode
acontecer nesse caso? O juiz nomeará, de
acordo com o processo civil, um curador
especial, que geralmente é a defensoria
pública, para tomar conta dos interesses
deste filho menor que está como autor
contra os seus pais, porque em condições
normais os pais que representariam os
filhos. E aí, se o juiz consentir,
se a sentença for
de procedência,
a pessoa casa
e ela está emancipada.
OK? Agora temos uma regra importante,
regrinha de ouro. Eu posso casar com 16
anos.
Aí vem o nosso artigo
1520.
O 1520
estabelece
o seguinte,
o o artigo 1520 estabelece o seguinte,
gente, antes de falar do 1520, vocês vão
me dar minutinhos só para pegar um copo
d'água e voltar, tá? Não sai daí.
Rapidinho, rapidinho, rapidinho,
rapidinho. M.
[música]
>> [música]
>> H
[música]
>> Voltei.
Deixa eu botar meu microfone
e só pegar uma aguinha
de que, né, professor? Tava aqui
morrendo seca.
Vamos lá, então. Olha só, o artigo 1520,
ele fala da idade Núbi pro casamento.
Antigamente a gente poderia,
Eliana Prado, um beijo, viu? Obrigada
por tá sempre aí presente nas nossas
aulas, ajudando aqui na moderação do
chat.
O 1520, ele dizia o seguinte: "Será
possível o casamento, olha só, será
possível o casamento
para menor de 16 anos em caso de
gravidez ou para evitar pena de estupro?
Isso não é mais possível,
gente. Cuidado, não tem mais
possibilidade nenhuma de casamento de
menor de 16 anos, tá? Não tem mais
possibilidade nenhuma nenhuma nenhuma de
casamento de menor de 16 anos. Então, de
acordo com o 1520,
nós vamos ter agora a seguinte situação.
Até botar assim, ó.
Olha
só, o 1520
estabelece muito claramente
Em nenhum caso será permitido o
casamento de menor de 16 anos em nenhuma
circunstância,
em nenhum caso. OK? Então, muito cuidado
com isso aí, certo? Muito cuidado com
isso aí.
Tudo bem? Dá o print nessa tela aí.
Seguindo o bonde.
Seguindo o bonde. Mais um ponto
importante pra gente falar aqui sobre
família.
Como eu mencionei para você,
seja
no casamento,
seja no casamento,
seja
na união
estável,
seja No casamento.
Presta atenção agora.
Seja no casamento,
seja na união estável, nós teremos
obrigatoriamente
uma regra.
Não tem opção.
Uma regra
de
regime
de bens.
obrigatoriamente,
seja no casamento,
seja na união estável, nós teremos
[roncando]
obrigatoriamente
uma regra de regime de bens.
Não tem para onde fugir.
Obrigatoriamente nós teremos regra de
regime de bens. Agora, professora, qual
que é
qual que é o regime de bens que nós
vamos ter? A incidência, como eu
mencionei,
a pessoa poderá ter a incidência do
regime de bens
de duas formas.
Esta escolha pode decorrer do próprio
silêncio,
presta atenção agora, do próprio
silêncio ou
da vontade
expressa.
E se é uma vontade expressa, óbvio, tem
que ser por escrito.
Então, pode acontecer
pelo silêncio
ou
pela vontade expressa. Vou até mudar
isso aqui. Vou fazer uma setinha,
tá? Pode ser pela vontade expressa ou
pelo silêncio. Professora, pelo silêncio
eu faço o quê? Pelo silêncio,
né? Ou seja, eu vou casar e não faço uma
escolha expressa. Tô lá casando e vida
que segue biibi bobó. Pelo silêncio,
eu vou ter o quê?
a incidência da comunhão parcial de
bens, que é o chamado então regime
supletório. Casei ou vivo uma união
estável e não escolhi de maneira
expressa, a regra é a comunhão parcial
de bens. Enquanto então quando uma
questão de prova falar para você assim,
João e Maria são casados no regime da
separação de bens,
João e Maria são casados desde 2010.
Se não falar qual que é o regime, eu vou
observar o regime da comunhão parcial de
bens, tá bom?
E temos uma outra situação que eu vou
falar para você já já. Vou deixar a
bolinha pronta aqui, mas eu falo já já
para você.
de maneira expressa, de maneira
expressa,
de maneira expressa,
na união estável,
eu escolho de um jeito.
No casamento eu escolho de outro jeito.
Então, vamos lá. Na união estável,
eu escolho
o regime
por meio de uma escritura
pública. A lei não fala do formato de
escolha do regime de bens na união
estável. Então, por simetria, a gente
aplica a regra do do casamento.
E para o casamento,
para o casamento,
essa escolha é feita por um pacto
anteupcial,
tá? E Roberta, pela vontade expressa, eu
posso escolher o quê?
comunhão universal,
separação de bens e participação final
nosestos. Então eu vou recapitular para
você. Não gostei dessa forma que eu
escrevi isso aqui. Eu vou escrever de
novo. Então vamos recapitular. Vou botar
assim, ó.
No casamento
ou
na união
estável. Eu tenho que ter
obrigatoriamente a incidência do regime
de bens. Vou botar mais claro aqui. Eu
tenho que ter obrigatoriamente a
incidência
de regime de bens. Esse regime de bens
será imposto pelo silêncio dos nubentes
ou dos conviventes. E aí nós vamos ter a
incidência da comunhão parcial de bens.
Então, se a banca trouxer uma questão,
não mencionar qual que é o regime de
bens, você vai aplicar o quê? Você vai
aplicar a comunhão parcial de bens, tá?
Então, eu tenho aqui a incidência da
comunhão parcial de bens. Agora, eu
posso promover a minha escolha
de forma expressa. Se é uma forma
expressa, é óbvio que é de forma
escrita,
tá? De forma escrita. Eu posso ter na
união estável a feitura de uma escritura
pública, escolhendo outro regime. Que
outro regime? Comunão universal,
separação de bens ou participação final
dos acquestos. E eu posso ter a questão
do casamento, que é por meio do pacto
antenupcial.
O Código Civil não menciona sobre a
escritura pública da união estável, tá?
A gente segue a regra do pacto
antenopicial. O pacto antenopicial tem
previsão no artigo 1653.
E eu quero que você tenha muito cuidado
com esse artigo, porque ele também é um
artigo categoria de prova. E o que que a
gente vai observar? Dá um print nessa
tela aí, que essa tela aí ficou top,
top, topzeira. Dá um print aí. Olha
isso.
1 653.
É nulo,
é nulo,
é nulo
o pacto antenupcial se não for feito por
escritura pública
e será ineficaz
se não lhe seguir o casamento.
OK? Olha essa questão que caiu na prova
da OAB. Foi mais ou menos assim.
Eh, foi mais ou menos assim.
Eh, o Robson é muito ridículo. Olha a
pergunta dele. É verdade que quando vai
assinar no cartório para casar, o
diretor do presídio vai estar junto do
juiz? Robson, para, tá, me erra. Claro
que é verdade.
Brincadeira. Olha essa questão que caiu
na pro. É uma questão muito top.
Eh, eu vou florear um pouco a questão
aqui, né? Eu vou dar uns detalhes,
aumentar para fazer um tom dramático,
Helena do Leblão, porque vocês sabem que
eu sou Helena do Leblon de Manuel
Carlos.
Um sofrimento
sem fim, um drama, mas no final eu
venço. Olha isso.
Imagina você que o João
era apaixonado pela Maria. Maria era o
presente de Deus da vida do João e eles
resolveram se casar. Quando eles
resolveram se casar,
eles ingressaram com o processo de
habilitação no cartório. Eu vou falar
desse processo de habilitação já já.
Eles ingressaram com processo de
habilitação no cartório. Deu tudo certo.
Saiu a certidão autorizando a casar.
Nesse meio período, eles fizeram o pacto
antenupcial
no cartório.
Eles fizeram um pacto antenupcial no
cartório e escolheram o regime da
separação
separação de bens. Tá entendendo a
história?
Depois que eles fizeram isso,
o João,
vamos botar que tudo isso aqui aconteceu
em 2010, tá? O João ficou doente.
João ficou doente. Ficou internado
um ano no hospital
e quando ele saiu, eles decidiram
não casar. O João falou assim: "Maria,
não vamos casar não. Vamos viver nossa
vidinha,
vamos lá pro nosso apartamento,
vamos viver nossa vida junto, vamos
seguir o bonde", né? E eles passaram a
viver uma
união estável,
ficaram juntos. Então, desde aquela
época até agora, em 2026,
o João
chega para Maria e fala: "Maria,
seguinte é:
Não pense que lhe quero o mal.
Leid, um beijo, viu, Maria? Não pense
que lhe quer o mal. Apenas não te quero
mais.
Porque o João encontrou a Antônia e ele
falou: "Cara, Maria não é meu presente
de Deus, é a Antônia. Não quero mais a
Maria. Maria, não pense que lhe quero
mal. Apenas não te quero mais.
Maria
simp. Olha isso, gente. Olha a história.
É simplesmente
simplesmente
o cara do Neida chega e fala:
"Maria, ficamos juntos esses anos
inteiros.
Nós não casamos, vivemos uma união
estável.
Vivemos uma união estável.
E agora eu não te quero mais.
Aí
a Maria olha
e fala: "Uai, João,
mim,
moleque.
Ô linda Maria, né?
Tá tudo bem, não sou obrigada. Aliás,
João, tudo bem. Ninguém é obrigado a
amar ninguém, não é mesmo?
Ninguém é obrigado a amar ninguém.
De modo que eu sei que você agora é o
meu ex-amor.
Eis amor, gostaria que tu soubesse
o quanto eu sofri
ao ter que me afastar de ti. Eu não
chorei.
Eu não chorei. Na verdade, como uma
louca, eu até sofri, mas no fundo só eu
sei as angústias que senti, porque na
vida sempre sonhamos com o mais amor.
Infelizmente, eu lamento, João, mas não
deu. Nos desgastamos
transformando tudo em dor. Mas mesmo
assim, João, eu acredito que valeu.
Quando a saudade bate forte, é
envolvente. Eu me possuo é na sua
intenção,
com minha cuca naqueles momentos quentes
em que se acelerava o meu coração. Mas
você virou o meu ex-amor. De fato,
ninguém é obrigado a amar ninguém. Já
que não me queres mais.
me dê o que é meu. E o João vai falar
assim:
"Te dar o que é seu?"
Como assim te dar o que é seu? Eu tenho
em minhas mãos
um documento.
Eu tenho em minhas mãos um documento
que leva o nome
Eu tenho em minhas mãos
um documento que leva o nome de Pacto
Antenupcial. Maria foi feito no
cartório.
Ó o João achando que tá se dando bem.
Foi feito no cartório.
E nesse documento, Maria, a gente
escolheu o regime da separação de bens.
É ou não é verdade?
É ou não é verdade, Maria? Tá tudo no
meu nome, minha querida.
Some da minha vida.
A Maria vai olhar e vai falar assim:
"Amor, baixa
a mãozinha".
Tá, meu amor, eu sei. Nós temos esse
documento que nós fizemos no cartório.
Esse documento é válido.
É válido, meu amor.
Lindo, maravilhoso. Realmente você tem
razão. Esse documento é válido.
Porém, contudo, entretanto, todavia,
João, acredito que você, mesmo formado
em direito, que como não estudou pelo
grão AB, não passou no exame de ordem
até hoje, e eu que estudei no grão AB,
passei no exame de ordem, tive aula com
a professora Roberta, que inclusive eu
vou contratá-la agora para fazer o nosso
divórcio, ela me contou nas aulas que
este pacto antenupcial, ele feito por
escritura, realmente ele é válido, meu
amor, mas uma coisa é validade. Outra
coisa é efeito.
Na escada ponteana você tem no primeiro
degrau existência, no segundo degrau
validade, no terceiro degrau eficácia.
Esse documento existe, ele é válido,
posto que feito no cartório, lindo.
Porém, meu amor, ele não produziu
efeito. Sabe por, meu querido? Você
deveria estudar um pouquinho mais. Se
você utilizasse
a sua criatividade para estudar, talvez
você não estivesse passando essa
vergonha nesse momento. A gente não
casou, a gente foi viver uma união
estável. E esse documento só produz
efeito se nós casarmos. Então, nós temos
um pacto antenupcial que é válido. Sim,
é válido.
É válido,
mas ele é
ineficaz.
Por quê? Porque a gente nunca casou. E
aí, meu querido, como a gente
não fez um documento específico para
união estável, prevalece a regra do
silêncio, amor meu. Então aqui
a nossa o nosso regime da comunhão
parcial de bens, tudo que foi adquirido
onerosamente na constância da nossa
união, ainda que esteja em seu nome,
somente é nosso. Então, portanto,
querido,
vá para o quinto dos infernos e vamos
dividir meio a meio tudo que foi
adquirido na constância dessa união.
Curtiu?
Seguinte, é aqui não tem esse negócio de
gentileza, não.
Tá bom?
Então o pacto antenupcial para produzir
efeitos, ele precisa seguir o casamento.
Se o casamento não foi celebrado,
oh coitadinho.
Inclusive, João, quero te dizer que
você,
ao me informar do fim do nosso
relacionamento, você tira de minhas
costas um peso muito grande, porque eu
também conheci o amor da minha vida e eu
só estava preocupada em como eu ia lhe
comunicar que eu tava com pena de você.
Mas graças a Deus você já me comunicou.
Eu já posso seguir a minha vida com o
Ricardão.
Dá o print, né, lindo? Ai. Aí ele vai
chegar e falar: "Maria, você ainda é o
amor da minha vida. Eu estava
equivicado.
tá porquento dos infernos,
desgraçado maldito.
OK, tudo bem. Então é nulo se não for
feito por escritura pública e ineficaz
se não seguir o casamento. Como o
casamento não foi celebrado, aquele
documento não produz efeitos. Então a
comunhão parcial de bens. Mas
professora, o que que eu divido mesmo?
O café ainda tá quente, já tá é frio e
eu não tô nem aí.
>> [risadas]
>> E para piorar, a Maria encerra assim:
João, o que fez com que eu parasse de te
amar é o seu bafo. Você tem bafo.
Menta o áudio
e pronto.
Aí vamos lá.
[risadas]
Essa Maria é uma bandida. Enganou meu
amigo. Enganou seu amigo. Coisa nenhuma.
Seu amigo que tava querendo se dar bem.
Mas o mal do esperto é achar que só a
mãe dele faz filho esperto.
Esse é o mal do esperto.
João indo para o psiquiatra em 3 2 1.
Adoro.
Mas Roberta, no final das contas
Poisal, Roberta, cheguei a pensar aqui
que Maria era a vítima. Eu vi um meme no
Instagram assim, contei para ele que eu
venho de um relacionamento tóxico
e ele com piedade de mim ficou com pena
e falou: "Meu amor, você nunca mais vai
sofrer esse tipo de coisa." Aí mostra a
cabecinha assim, olhando.
Só que eu não contei que eu era a
tóxica. [risadas]
Risada de bruxa. Pois vamos lá.
Vamos lá.
No final das contas, a gente tem os
regimes de bens. E o que que eu
partilho, o que que eu não partilho,
como é que funciona, que que eu que tá
acontecendo na fila da goiaba, por Vamos
lá desenhar os nossos regêmeas de bens.
Vamos lá, segue o bonde. Aqui nós vamos
dividir nosso material em dois, em
quatro partes.
Meus aluninhos já estão acostumados com
esse desenho.
E é isso. Olha lá.
Olha lá,
gente.
Eu tenho quais modalidades de regime de
bens?
Deixa eu fazer um negócio mais bonito
aqui. Quais as modalidades de regime de
bens? Vai falando comigo aí porque eu
vou botar uns negócios aqui.
Quais as modalidades? Vamos lá. Comunhão
parcial de bens.
Comunhão parcial de bens.
Calma que eu tô arrumando material. Se
controle.
Separação de bens.
Calma que eu tô arrumando material.
Larga de ser louco.
Não tem aquele negócio do Faustão, quem
sabe faz ao vivo. Pois é.
Nós temos,
sério, eu tenho um ódio de est fazendo
isso aqui acontecer esses negócios.
Nós temos,
vocês querem ver o que que eu tô
fazendo? Eu mostro. Vamos lá. Nós temos
a
comunhão universal de bens,
univer
sal de bens.
E nós temos a participação,
participação
final nos acquestos,
tá? Nós temos essas quatro modalidades.
Quatro modalidades. Professora, explica
aí pra gente como é que funciona cada
uma dessas modalidades. Vamos lá. Cada
uma delas. Para explicar, a gente
precisa dos nossos
bonequin, né? Nossos bonequinhos. Então,
vou botar aqui, ó,
nosso casal.
Vou botar aqui
homem com homem,
porque pode,
homem com mulher,
porque nós consideramos justa toda forma
de amor, né?
Mulher com mulher.
Sério, gente, é muito bom, né? Civil é
muito melhor que penal.
Então, olha lá, a gente tem aqui nossos
casais.
Nós vamos fazer um marco para delimitar
em que momento aconteceu o casamento,
tá? E esse marco vai ser o coraçãozinho
aqui, tá vendo?
Tá vendo?
OK.
Nós vamos ter então, portanto, a partir
do coração,
o que é
o relacionamento aqui de casal, a ou
considerando a união estável ou a eh o
casamento.
Quando a gente fala de comunhão parcial
de bens, a gente tem uma situação,
gente, presta atenção agora. A gente tem
uma situação,
uma situação antes do casamento,
que eu vou deixar de vermelho, e uma
situação
depois do casamento, que eu vou deixar
de verde.
Então, a gente [limpando a garganta] tem
a categoria dos bens que a gente tem
antes do casamento, que a gente chama de
bens particulares,
e a categoria que a gente tem depois do
casamento, que a gente chama de bens
comuns,
tá?
Ou seja, pode acontecer de uma pessoa
ter antes do casamento os seus próprios
bens.
Aqui, tá vendo as bolinhas vermelha?
cada um com seu cada um e ao longo do
casamento juntos eles adquirirem os bens
comuns. Tá vendo? Ou pode acontecer de
ninguém ter nada na vida, juntar e
construir um patrimônio junto. Então eu
posso ter comunhão parcial de bens
com bens particulares, que é essa
situação aqui, e comunhão parcial de
bens
bens particulares, que é essa situação
aqui. A gente só angareou o patrimônio
comum. É isso que pode acontecer,
professora. Então, quer dizer que a lei
considera como bem comum
o quê? Que que é bem comum? Vamos puxar
uma setinha aqui pro bem verde. O que
que seria bem comum?
Loteria.
O que você adquiriu após? Ah, Roberto,
eu ganhei na Mega Cena. É dos dois? Dos
dois, porque é fato eventual. O que você
adquiriu após o casamento a título
oneroso, pagando por ele? Ah, mas tá só
no nome do João, não importa. É dos
dois. O que você recebeu a título de
aluguel de bem particular? Isso aqui é
muito interessante. Imagina que você é
casado no regime da comunhão parcial de
bens e aí você tá lá bem, muito bem
tranquilo. Você tem um apartamento que
você tem antes do bem particular ou
antes do casamento que é bem particular.
Aí você aluga esse apartamento e você
fica de guardando o aluguel. Se você
guarda o aluguel montando uma poupança e
esse aluguel é fruto do bem comum, do
bem particular. É fruto do bem
particular. Então é dos dois, divide,
tá? É dos dois, divide.
aluguel particular, o Figuetes,
o FGTS, meu amigo, é dos dois pelo tempo
que você trabalhou na constância do
casamento. Não vem com essa, não. É dos
dois.
O que que é considerado bem particular?
O que você tem antes do casamento.
Eu tinha um apartamento antes do
casamento. Durante o casamento, eu vendi
aquele apartamento e comprei outro. Ele
continua sendo bem particular, porque
ele é subrogado no outro. O que entra
para você de herança
e doação ao longo do casamento, se você
é casado no regime da comunhão parcial
de bens, comunhão parcial de bens, e aí
seu pai morreu e deixou uma herança para
você. O que entrou de herança para você,
mesmo que você tenha, mesmo que você
seja casado e que tenha entrado de
herança, é seu, só seu.
O seu pai te fez uma doação, você é
casado no regime da comunhão parcial de
bens, é só seu, tá? Então isso aqui são
coisas que você não pode esquecer.
E na comunhão universal de bens, na
comunhão universal de bens,
tudo que você tem antes, a partir do
casamento, é dos dois, porque só vira
categoria de bem comum. Tudo, tudo,
tudo, tudo, tudo vai ser dos dois. A
gente não vai ter nada de bem
particular. Só o que eventualmente
entrar a título de doação ou herança com
cláusula de incomunicabilidade. Aí entra
só para você. O resto é nosso, tá? E na
categoria de separação de bens,
separação de bens. O que você tem antes
é só seu, o que você adquirir depois
também é só seu. De modo que é cada qual
seu cada qual. Tá vendo? Aqui eu só
tenho categoria de bens particulares.
Só que a separação de bens, ela pode ser
de duas formas. Olha pro quadro agora.
Ela só pode ser de duas formas. Ela pode
ser
convencional porque as partes escolhem
por meio do pacto.
Ou ela pode ser obrigatória
porque ela é imposta. pela lei.
Ela é imposta pela lei.
Professora, quando ela é obrigatória
imposta pela lei, ela é imposta para
quem?
Para quem tem mais de 70 anos. Calma que
eu vou falar sobre isso. Para quem casa
mediante causa
suspensiva lá do 1523.
e para quem necessitou
do suprimento judicial pro casamento, da
autorização judicial do casamento.
Mas professora,
assim, deixa eu entender.
Quem tem mais de 70 anos, o Supremo não
deu uma decisão diferente agora,
recente? Deu.
Que que foi? Olha para mim.
Quem tem mais de 70 anos, e isso consta
no 1641 do Código Civil, quem tem mais
de 70 anos, pela redação original do
Código Civil, tem que casar no regime da
separação de bens para evitar o golpe do
baú, para evitar, né, enfim.
Só que o que que o Supremo falou? O
Supremo falou, gente, não tem a menor,
não tem a menor condição,
né? O Supremo falou: "Não tem a menor
condição. Uma pessoa com mais de 70
anos, ela pode ser
presidente do Brasil, administrar,
admin, pode ser administr.
Isso é um absurdo, isso é uma falta de
absurdo." E aí o que que aconteceu? Que
que rolou? rolou que o Supremo falou
assim: "Para tudo, quem tem mais de 70
anos pode escolher livremente o seu
regime de bens.
Pode casar na comunhão universal, pode.
Pode. Pode casar na comunhão parcial,
pode. Pode casar na participação final,
pode. Pode escolher separação de bens,
com certeza pode. Pode tudo. Só que tem
um detalhe.
Se a pessoa com mais de 70 anos não
escolher livremente o seu regime, não
for lá e falar: "Eu quero comunhão
universal de bens, eu quero isso, eu
quero aquilo". Se ela não fizer isso,
para ela será aplicado o regime da
separação de bens. Então, nós temos um
outro regime supletório
no silêncio. Para quem tem mais de 70
anos,
se essa pessoa com mais de 70 anos não
escolher, o regime será da separação de
bens, que para ele será o regime
supletório, entendeu? Então, hoje nós
temos dois tipos de regime supletório.
O a comunhão parcial de bens, para quem
não escolher expressamente outra
modalidade, mas para quem tem mais de 70
anos, o regime da separação de bens será
o regime supletório, tá? Será o regime
supletório.
OK? Tudo bem?
Belezura. Show de bola.
Beleza.
Marav gold, maravig gold. Lindio, lindo.
Dá o print nessa tela e vão voltar.
Então, tá. E a participação final nos
acquestos regime para quem tem muito
dinheiro. E aí a gente tem aqui
tudo bem particular,
cada qual seu cada qual.
Se no final das contas alguém ajudou a
comprar alguma coisa aí partilha. Por
isso que a gente faz uma participação
final nosestos.
Detalhe do coração.
Detalhe do coração. Informação
importante. Vou fazer um negócio aqui
diferente.
Que cocô, né? Mas é é isso que eu quero
mesmo. Não o cocô. Eu quero fazer um
negócio bonitinho, mas eu quero fazer
uma divisão aqui.
Por que que eu dividi assim? Porque eu
quero te dizer
que
vocês ficam aí fingindo que não entende.
Agora vocês vão entender.
Somente
haverá
meiação
onde
houver
bem comum.
Porque meção, gente,
é
metade do que é comum. Então, onde é que
tem bem comum? Onde tem bolinha verde.
Onde tem bolinha verde. E onde é que tem
bolinha verde? Na comunhão parcial de
bens e na comunhão universal de bens. E
na aula de sucessão, eu falei para você
que o cônjuge não concorre com os
descendentes
na separação de bens e na comunhão
parcial de bens, porque você só tem bens
comuns. Olha onde eu te contei isso
bem aqui.
Olha onde eu te contei isso bem aqui.
Falei para você, eu falei na comunhão
universal e na comunhão parcial de bens
bens particulares,
o cônjugido morto não divide com os
descendentes dele porque ele já tirou
ameção.
Olha o desenho, só tem bens comuns.
Então eu tiro ameação.
Tudo bem?
Beleza. Isso aqui a gente teve na aula
de ontem.
Somente haverá ameação onde houver
bem
comum.
Olha o toque da professora.
Ficou feio isso, né, gente?
Misericórdia.
fazer assim, ó.
Tudo bem, Maravig Gold? Dá o print nessa
tela aí.
Dá o print nessa tela aí,
tá?
Quais são os bens comuns na na comunhão
parcial de bens? São esses aqui que eu
anotei. E na comunhão universal de bens
é tudo, tudo que tinha antes, tudo que
adquiriu depois, tudo, tudo de tudo.
Certo?
Tudo bem? [roncando]
Agora vamos lá, vamos falar de um ponto
específico aqui. Professora,
dá o print.
casamento.
Estamos falando aqui do casamento.
Vamos falar aqui um ponto específico
do casamento.
O casamento ele tem dois momentos.
O primeiro momento, que é o momento
destinado
à habilitação,
né, que eu vou lá no cartório, levo os
meus documentos no cartório,
passo por um processo
de habilitação.
Vou botar mais para cá. Se esse processo
de habilitação der certo, o cartório
emite uma certidão autorizando que eu
case.
Ele vai emitir uma certidão me
autorizando a casar.
E essa certidão produz efeitos por 90
dias. Eu tenho 90 dias para casar,
tá?
Aí, dada essa certidão,
eu tenho que ir lá
e marcar
o meu casamento, que é a celebração do
casamento.
Eu vou lá e marco a celebração do
A celebração do casamento é o momento de
dizer o sim.
Nessa celebração eu tenho que levar as
minhas
testemunhas,
tá? Eu tenho que levar minhas
testemunhas.
Essas testemunhas serão em número de
duas testemunhas.
Se a celebração for no próprio cartório,
será do número de quatro testemunhas se
a celebração for em edifício particular.
E será em quatro testemunhas se alguém
não souber ou não puder escrever,
porque uma vai assinar lá pela pessoa
que não sabe escrever, tá? Então, a
celebração é o momento de dizer o sim.
Celebrou, emite uma
certidão de casamento. Tá bom? Agora,
professora, é possível
casar
de maneira excepcional
com casos excepcionais? Que que você me
diz? Nós temos três casos excepcionais.
Casamento
por
procuração,
casamento em caso de moléstia grave.
e casamento em artículo mortes, que é na
extremidade da morte. São três formas
especiais de casamento
que estão previstas nos respectivos
artigos
1542,
1540.
Tá?
O casamento por procuração é aquele
casamento feito
por
procuração no sentido, ah, eu não vou
poder estar presente no dia do meu
casamento. Eu quero que alguém celebre o
meu casamento, que alguém manifeste a
minha vontade por mim. Quando você quer
que alguém manifeste a vontade por você,
você tá passando uma procuração. Beleza?
Eu vou lá e faço minha procuração.
[roncando]
Tá frio já. Eu vou lá e faço minha
procuração. Eu posso? Posso,
eu tenho que outorgar poderes
por instrumento público. Então, tem que
ser uma procuração por instrumento
público feita no cartório com poderes
especiais
para o casamento. Ou seja, se eu passo a
procuração para alguém vender meu carro,
eu não posso, ela não pode casar no meu
nome, né?
E essa procuração tem efeito por 90
dias.
Essa procuração tem efeito por 90 dias,
tá?
Em moléstia grave é quando um dos
nubentes está muito doente. Aí a
autoridade celebrante vai até o local.
Nesse caso aqui,
o povo já está habilitado,
já tem lá a certidão de habilitação,
essa certidão aqui.
A autoridade celebrante
vai até o local do enfermo
com duas testemunhas
e celebra o casamento.
Intículo mortes é o casamento não
compativo.
Esse casamento é quando a pessoa tá na
eminência da morte e fala: "Gente, pelo
amor de Deus,
sofri um acidente aqui, né? Caiu a laje
em cima de mim, eu tô aqui morrendo.
Chama o amor da minha vida, porque eu
quero antes de morrer, casar com ele."
Ou a pessoa tá no hospital morrendo,
chama o amor da vida e fala: "Eu quero
casar com você antes de morrer". é o
casamento na extremidade da vida, no
início da morte mesmo. Esse casamento
ele é celebrado
quando há risco,
né, de vida ali.
Mesmo que não haja habilitação,
eu caso na presença
de seis testemunhas
que depois da minha morte levarão para o
juiz a manifestação da minha última
vontade no casamento,
tá? levarão para o juiz a minha
manifestação de vontade no casamento.
OK? Certo? Então, essas são as regras
sobre casamento. Professor, e como que
termina
o casamento e a união estável?
Termina com a morte
de um dos dois, mas pode terminar também
com o final do amor. Para a união
estável, a gente fala em dissolução da
união estável e para o casamento a gente
fala em divórcio.
Vamos anotar. Olha só, dá o print aí na
tela. 3 2 1. Depois eu volto para dar o
print em tudo, tá? Vamos lá. Oh,
como que fica? O fim do amor aqui.
Como que fica o fim do amor? Eu tenho os
dois casos,
a união estável
e o casamento.
Tanto a dissolução quanto o divórcio
podem ser feitos no cartório,
tá?
Tanto a dissolução da união estável
quanto o divórcio pode ser feito no
cartório.
Na união estável, então nós temos a
dissolução
da união estável,
ou seja, a gente vai desfazer a união
estável. Pode ser um cartório por
escritura pública ou pode ser judicial
por meio de uma sentença. E nós vamos
ter
o divórcio,
né? O divórcio
ele pode ser no cartório ou pode ser
judicial.
O fato é que na dissolução
você vai, se não tiver uma escritura
pública reconhecendo o início da união,
você vai pedir o reconhecimento
do início da união
mais o período
dessa união mais a partilha de bens.
Lembrando que a partilha de bens não é
obrigatória, eu posso deixar para
resolver em outra ação, tá?
E o divórcio, o divórcio
você já tem a certidão de casamento,
então você não precisa comprovar eh
pedir o reconhecimento judicial do
início do casamento, porque você já tem
uma certidão de casamento.
O divórcio
não exige
tempo mínimo.
Antigamente, antes da emenda
constitucional 66 de 2010, eu tinha que
ficar casado por um tempo. Olha a merda.
Eu tinha que ficar casado por um ano. Aí
eu separava,
esperava um ano para poder pedir o
divórcio. Então eu tinha que ficar pelo
menos dois anos com aquele traste. Não
existe mais isso. Casou na quinta, quer
divorciar na segunda, pois vá, não tem
mais essa história, tá? Então não existe
mais tempo mínimo para ser aguardado
para eu poder pedir o divórcio. Não
existe mais isso.
E não precisa, isso aqui já caiu em
prova também.
Não
precisa
partilhar
bens
imediatamente.
Você é muito comum que você ajuíze o
divórcio com a partilha de bens, né? é
muito comum, mas pode acontecer de você
divorciar e deixar para discutir a
partilha de bens depois, não tem
problema nenhum, ok? Então, essa daqui é
a regra de eh
de solução e de divórcio.
Quero conversar com você também sobre um
ponto importante.
Os pais possuem sobre os seus filhos o
chamado poder familiar. Já, já, já, já,
já estamos terminando. Os pais possuem
sobre os seus filhos o chamado poder
familiar. O que que é o poder familiar?
É o poder que os pais possuem de gestão,
decisão, controle, administração da vida
dos filhos. Atenção agora, o poder
familiar é inerente à condição de pai e
mãe.
O pai e a mãe divorcia.
O divórcio não aumenta e nem diminui o
poder familiar dos pais. O poder
familiar continua existindo,
mas quando os pais não conseguem
conviver juntos, né, não estão casados
ou alguma coisa do tipo, o poder
familiar ele vai passar por uma uma
gestão
com a fixação da guarda. Então, a guarda
é um meio de gestão da execução do poder
familiar, que é muito maior do que
guarda.
Quem tem a guarda e quem tem a visita
não tem mais ou menos poder familiar. O
poder familiar não se fraciona, ele é
único.
Mas para facilitar a gestão da vida para
os pai e a mãe que não vive junto, a
gente tem um poder familiar. Aliás, se
uma pessoa tem paternidade e maternidade
biológica e tem paternidade ou
maternidade socioafetiva,
convive junto, né? convive junto.
A maternidade, a paternidade
sócioafetiva, não exclui a biológica,
assim como a biológica não exclui a
sócioafetiva. E todo mundo tem o poder
familiar. Então, é possível que uma
pessoa tenha vários pais, vários avós,
várias mães, não tem problema nenhum,
tá? E a sócioafetividade surge
independentemente de adoção, gente. São
coisas diferentes.
Então, nós temos três tipos de guarda.
Dá uma olhada aqui.
Nós temos três tipos de guarda. Nós
temos a guarda unilateral, a guarda
alternada e a guarda compartilhada. A
guarda compartilhada nós sabemos que é a
preferência, né?
Mas quando, isso aqui já é novidade na
lei, quando os pais manifestam que não
tem interesse na guarda compartilhada, o
juiz não pode importa compartilhada,
né? E a guarda compartilhada, gente,
cuidado, cuidado. A guarda compartilhada
não exonera de pagar alimentos, não
desobriga ao pagamento dos alimentos. O
menor tem um lar de referência ou com o
pai ou com a mãe, tem que pagar
alimentos normalmente. Tem gente que
fala: "Ah, eu quero a guarda
compartilhada porque aí no período que
tá comigo vai ter os meus gastos, no
período que tá com outro tem os gastos
do outro. Então não tem que pagar
alimentos, tá errado. Tem que pagar
alimentos. Na guarda compartilhada você
tem a fixação dos alimentos, tá?
Eh,
então, né, a gente tem aqui o pagamento
dos alimentos e tem o lar de referência.
Agora, cuidado, o poder familiar pode
ser perdido,
tá? O poder familiar ele pode ser
perdido. E quando é que você perde o
poder familiar? Por decisão judicial.
Existe a destituição do poder familiar e
as causas estão no 1638.
O que eu quero que você observe
é que é possível perder o poder familiar
por violência doméstica. Violência
doméstica. O pai que pratica violência
doméstica em face da mãe dos filhos
menores perde o poder familiar. Agora,
poder familiar é em relação a filhos
menores. Uma vez caiu no exame de ordem
assim: João é casado com a Maria e tem
três filhos, um maior e dois menores. O
João praticou violência doméstica em
face da Maria.
Ele perde o poder familiar em relação
aos três filhos? Não, porque poder
familiar só existe em relação a filhos
menores. Então ele perde o poder
familiar em relação aos filhos menores.
Filhos maiores, nada disso. OK?
dá o print nessa tela. E nós temos que
conversar também sobre um ponto
relacionado a alimentos.
Alimentos.
Alimentos
é uma situação
que cai muito em prova. Professora, e
como que eu fixo os alimentos? Pelo
Código Civil, a gente utiliza o binômio
necessidade,
possibilidade. Necessidade de quem
pleiteia os alimentos e possibilidade de
quem vai pagar os alimentos. Eu não
posso pedir um valor de alimentos se eu
não tenho possibilidade de receber
daquela pessoa. Então a gente verifica
necessidade, possibilidade, necessidade,
possibilidade.
E é óbvio que a gente também analisa a
proporcionalidade ou razoabilidade,
tá? Proporcionalidade ou razoabilidade.
Por quê?
Porque pode ser que quem ganha mais
possa pagar mais. O ideal é que entre os
devedores dos alimentos, por exemplo, o
filho precisa de R$ 5.000 para viver. A
mãe tem que arcar com R$ 2.500, o pai
com R$ 2.500.
Se o pai ou a mãe pode pagar um pouco
mais, a gente atribui uma uma
proporcionalidade entre eles, né? Um
paga 60%, o outro 40. Um paga 70, o
outro 30. Enfim, o juiz vai verificar
isso, mas pelo Código Civil, o binômio é
necessidade, possibilidade, mas a gente
pode verificar a necessidade,
possibilidade, proporcionalidade ou
razoabilidade.
E aí, gente, o que que acontece?
Esses alimentos são devidos entre
pais e filhos,
né? O pai ele paga pro filho, mas na
velice dos pais o filho pode pagar pros
pais.
São devidos
de um cônjuge
pro outro
no divórcio ou na dissolução da união
estável
e são devidos
entre os
irmãos.
Se um irmão precisa para viver. Ah,
Roberta, tio paga para sobrinho? Não.
Primo paga para para primo, não. Não,
não, não, não. Tá lembrando que os
alimentos devidos de um cônjuge pro
outro, via de regra,
via de regra são
temporários.
Pera aí, gente, rapidinho. Me dá um
minutinho.
Pronto, gente. Tive que atender aqui o
telefone rapidinho.
Então, olha só, é, a gente tem aqui
o seguinte, a gente tem aqui, é, a
questão do dos alimentos devidos de um
cônjuge pro outro de maneira temporária,
né, para restabelecer a vida, porque foi
casado muito tempo, às vezes deixou de
trabalhar e aí vai restabelecer a vida,
tá?
os alimentos
de pais para filhos e geralmente cai em
prova dos pais pagando para os filhos.
Eu quero que você lembre que o
desemprego do pai não é causa para
deixar de pagar alimentos.
Maioridade dos filhos também não é causa
para deixar de pagar alimentos
automaticamente.
Tampouco a prisão do pai.
Não se deixa de pagar alimentos porque
tá desempregado, porque o filho é maior
ou porque o pai tá preso.
Porque nesse sentido nós vamos observar
a súmula 358 do STJ.
Para exonerar do pagamento dos
alimentos,
eu tenho que observar o quê, gente? o
contraditório,
tá? Eu tenho que observar o
contraditório
aí.
Aí cai na prova,
ah, o pai tá desempregado, então ele
pode parar de pagar alimentos? Não. Ah,
o filho completou maioridade, então ele
pode deixar de pagar alimentos? Não. Ah,
o pai foi preso, a mãe foi presa, deixa
de pagar alimentos? Não, porque para
esonerar
dos alimentos, eu tenho que garantir o
contraditório.
Isso aqui vive caindo em prova.
Inclusive caiu recentemente sobre a
prisão,
tá? Eu tenho que garantir o
contraditório. OK, professora.
E quando
e quando
eu posso acionar os avós? A voz também
tem uma regra muito importante.
Alimentos
avoengos.
Os alimentos avoengos devidos pelos
avós, né? são aqueles devidos pelos
avós, porque se os pais não têm condição
de pagar, eu aciono os avós.
Esses alimentos estão previstos
na súmula 596
do STJ. Eu só aciono os avós.
Eu só aciono os avós quando estou diante
dos alimentos
de forma subsidiária.
Os pais não têm como pagar
e complementares.
Eu não posso
acionar direto os avós. Eu não posso
acionar direto os a voz
de maneira
eh de cara antes de cobrar dos pais. Eu
não posso fazer isso, tá? Não posso
fazer isso. Então eu só vou acionar os
avós se os pais não tiverem condição
nenhuma.
E um último detalhe, eu falei para você
que os pais pagam alimentos para os
filhos, mas pode ter um determinado
momento na vida dos pais que os pais
precisam dos alimentos. Os alimentos são
divisíveis entre os devedores. Por isso
que se o filho precisa de R$ 5.000 para
viver, o pai paga R$ 2.500, a mãe paga
R500. é divisível
entre os devedores. Mas quando se trata,
vou puxar um OBS aqui, quando se trata
de alimentos devidos ao idoso, e quem é
o idoso, é quem tem mais de 60 anos.
Pelo Estatuto do Idoso, esses alimentos
são solidários. Ou seja, se aquele pai
precisa dos alimentos e ele tem três
filhos,
se esse pai for idoso acima dos 60 anos,
ele
pode cobrar tudo que ele precisa de um
só dos filhos. Ele não precisa cobrar
1/3 do filho um, 1/3 do filho dois, 1/3
do filho três. Ele pode cobrar o valor
total de qualquer um dos filhos. Porque
você tem que lembrar que a solidariedade
causa exatamente isso. Belezura? Show de
bola. Vamos dar o print na telinha, nas
telinhas que nós fizemos hoje.
Hoje a gente trabalhou o direito das
famílias
e nós conversamos, eu vou mudando os
slides e você vai dando print. E nós
conversamos sobre união estável e
casamento, os requisitos.
Nós falamos dos impedimentos pro
casamento.
Quem não pode casar não pode viver união
estável. Nós falamos da idade para
casar, que é a idade núbil. Nós
conversamos do sobre regime de bens e
como que a gente promove a escolha. E
hoje a pessoa com mais de 70 anos pode
escolher livremente o seu regime de
bens.
Se ela não escolher, aí vai ser
separação de bens. Nós conversamos sobre
o pacto antenupcial e falamos dessa
situação aí do João e da Maria.
Nós falamos do que que é partilhado na
comunhão parcial de bens, na comunhão
universal, na separação de bens, na
participação final nosestos. Lembre-se
que nós teremos meação só quando for
caso específico,
específico de bens comuns.
Falamos do casamento, que é possível
casar por procuração, que é possível
casamento em caso de moléstia grave, o
casamento na extremidade da vida.
Nós falamos da dissolução da união
estável, do casamento pelo divórcio.
Nós falamos do poder familiar, da
destituição do poder familiar, que só
acontece por decisão judicial,
tá? E nós falamos também aqui da questão
dos alimentos. Esses são os temas que
podem estar na sua prova. [roncando]
São temas muito categoria de direito
civil. São temas cativos de prova, tá? E
os nossos encontros continuam.
Eu vou postar lá no meu Instagram
@robertakeiroz,
o nosso próximo encontro,
nosso próximo encontro que será um
encontro sobre direito das coisas. Vamos
falar sobre posse, propriedade, um monte
de coisa bacana, detenção, questões de
prova
e vai acontecer semana que vem. Eu vou
postar as datas. Semana que vem nós
temos dois encontros de coisas e de
responsabilidade civil. São encontros
assim, ó, chuchu, beleza? Tá bom? Espero
que você tenha gostado desse encontro.
Se você quiser esse material aqui, eu
vou já postar um link lá no meus stories
do Instagram já. E você tem que clicar
nesse link e se inscrever paraa nossa
revisão de véspera. Porque aí o que que
vai acontecer? Você vai receber um
caderno de direito civil feito
pessoalmente à mão por mim.
E aí com certeza você vai acertar todas
as questões de direito civil. Então
simplesmente, meus queridos,
simplesmente pura e simplesmente esteja
ligado, tá? Eu vou mandar um
coraçãozinho agora aqui para vocês no
chat e vocês clicando nesse coração vão
ter acesso ao meu canal aqui do YouTube
Direito como nunca se viu. Vai lá, se
inscreva no meu canal também tem um
monte de conteúdo bacana para vocês. E
nessa reta final continuem ligados aqui
no nosso grão AB, porque é aqui que tem
uma aprovação com toda certeza,
especialmente para você, tá bom? Beijo,
beijo, fiquem bem, até a próxima. Ciao.
Ciao.
[música]